اسمحي لي وسائل الاعلام اسرائيليه اعتقال
فلسطيني من الخليل لاشتباه بتنفيذه عمليات
الدهس والطعن في رعنانا اذا نقلا عن وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه اعتقال فلسطيني من الخليل
الاشتباه بتنفيذه عمليات الدهس والطعن في
رعنانا هذا هو اخر خبر في سياق ما يسميه
الجانب الاسرائيلي حتى الان حدثا
استثنائيا اعتقال فلسطيني من الخليل
الاشتباه بتنفيذه عمليات الدهس والطعن في
رعنانا نعود الى مراسله
نعم بالفعل وربما عبد السلام مع الاعلان
عن انه تم اعتقال مشتبه به بتنفيذ هذه
العمليه من مدينه الخليل جنوب الضفه ال
الغربيه ربما يتعزز الشعور لدى الشرطه
الاسرائيليه بانها عمليه وليست حادث طرق
لكن بطبيعه الحال قبل قليل فقط اعلن
الناطق باسم الشرطه الاسرائيليه لوسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه بانه لا يمكن ك التحديد
في هذه اللحظه او حتى هذه اللحظه اذا ما
كان الحديث يدور عن عمليه متعمده على
خلفيه امنيه ام انها حادث طرق من الواضح
بان التحقيقات مستمره في هذا حدث بعض
المصادر تشير الى انه تم
تحييد المنفذ وتم اعتقال شخص اخر من
الخليل وعندما تتحدث وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه وتستخدم مصطلح تحييد وهو
المصطلح ايضا الذي تستخدمه الشرطه
الاسرائيليه فهذا يحمل معنيين اما ان يكون
الحديث عن قتل المنفذ او عن اعتقاله هذا
هو المصطلح الرائج في وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه وفي ولدى الشرطه الاسرائيليه
عندما يتم الحديث عن عمليه يقدم على
تنفيذها شااب فلسطيني وبالتالي المعلومات
تشير الى انه تم اعتقال مشتبه به بتنفيذ
هذه العمليه من مدينه الخليل جنوب الضفه
الغربيه ولكن حتى الان يتم التحقيق مره
اخرى في ملابسات ما حدث اذا ما كان الدافع
جنائي لسرقه مركبات ام انه كان بالفعل
حادث متعمد للاستيلاء على مركبات في مدينه
رعنانا والقيام بعمليات دهس في اكثر من
موقع ال الشرطه الاسرائيليه حتى الان لم
تحدد فيما اذا كان هذا حادث طرق ام عمليه
ولكن مره اخرى يتعزز تتعزز الترجيحات
والتقديرات بانها عمليه على خلفيه امنيه
وقد دفعت الشرطه الاسرائيليه بتعزيزات
وقوات كبيره جدا الى الموقع ومنها ايضا
قوات خاصه للتعامل مع هذا الحدث وجمع
الادله واجراء تحقيقات اي في ملابسات هذه
العمليه من جهه
معو اذا سمحتي فق هذه الصور للتعزيزات
العسرى التي تتحدثين عنها في صوره مباشره
من رعنانا شمال تل ابيب وكما ذكرت هناك
تعزيزات ولاحظنا عدد كبير من القوات
الاسرائيليه تتجه الى المكان تم اخلاءه
كما واذا
رعنانا هذه لقطات مباشره منها المكان يبدو
خاليا الان السياره التي البيضاء التي يتم
الحديث عنها وحولها عدد من ال من يوصفون
بالباحثين الجنائيين عموما اي اذا الصوره
اوضح الان في لقطات مباشره على شاشه
الجزيره من رعنانا شمال تلبيب وكما نلاحظ
في الصوره عدد من رجال الشرطه والباحثين
الجنائيين حول السياره البيضاء التي يعتقد
انها استخدمت في عمليه الدس هيئه البث
الاسرائيليه عن مصادر امنيه تقول يبدو ان
هجوم رعنانا ارهابي وتم اعتقال مشتبه فيه
من سكان الخليل اذا هذا نقلا عن هيئه البث
الاسرائيليه عن مصادر امنيه يبدو ان هجوم
رعنانا ارهابي وتم اعتقال مشتبه فيه من
سكان الخليل ونلاحظ في الصوره تعزيزات
امنيه كبيره في
المنطقه في نقل مباشر لهذه الصوره من
رعنانا شمال تلبيب اعود اليك
نجوان نعم بالفعل اذا هو الشخص بحسب
التحقيقات الاوليه للشرطه الاسرائيليه
الشخص الذي تم اعتقاله هو الشخص الذي نفذ
عمليه دهس في اكثر من موقع وبحسب بيان
الشرطه الاولي وهي ايضا تتعامل وفقا
للبيان بحذر تقول بانه مشتبه به بتنفيذ
عمليه دهس بعد ان استولى على او بدل ثلاث
مركبات لاسرائيل انتقل من مركبه الى اخرى
بعد ان اصطدمت المركبه الاولى
بجدار جراء اصطدامه ايضا ب مجموعه من
الاسرائيليين عند معبر للمشاه ثم استولى
على مركبه اخرى وقام بدهس مجموعه اي اخ
مجموعه اخرى من الاسرائيليين في
ال الحادث نتحدث عن عده
اصابات وبحسب وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه
تحديدا القناه الرابعه ع قد اعلنت عن مقتل
واحده من المصابين امراه اسرائيليه قتلت
في هذه العمليه ولكن هذا لم يتم الاعلان
عنه في الاسعاف الاسرائيلي بعد الاسعاف
الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن اصابه حرجه للغايه
بالعاده عندما يعلنون ان هناك اصابه حرجه
للغايه هذا يعني بانها قتلت وهو ما اعلنت
عنه القناه الرابعه ع في التلفزه
الاسرائيليه لكن بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك
ثلاث اسرائيليين اصيبوا بجروح توصف بال
الخطيره عدد من الاصابات نقلوا الى مستشفى
بيلنسون في مدينه بيخ سكفا وايضا الى
واحده من مستشفيات مدينه تل ابيب اف هناك
عدد من الاصابات الخطيره كما ذكرنا
بالاضافه الى اصابات اخرى نقلت الى
المستشفيات الاسرائيليه في مدينه رانا
والمدن
القريبه منها من الواضح بان الشرطه
الاسرائيليه تجري تحقيقات واسعه وبالعاده
عندما يتم الاعلان عن ان السائق او منفذ
العمليه هو فلسطيني يتم تتعزز التقديرات
والترجيح لدى الشرطه الاسرائيليه والاجهزه
الامنيه بانها عمليه امنيه وليست حادث طرق
حتى في الاحداث الاخرى عبد السلام عندما
يكون هناك حادث طرق او عندما يكون هناك
خلل في المركبه وفقا لشهود عيان في مرات
سابقه لعمليات مماثله فانه في حاله اتضاح
ان السائق هو فلسطيني سواء كان من الضفه
الغربيه او من داخل الخط الاخضر يتم
التعامل مع مثل هذه العمليات بانها عمليات
ام امنيه لكن حتى الان الشرطه الاسرائيليه
اعلنت بانها قامت باعتقال مشتبه به يتم
التعامل معه بانه نفذ هذه العمليه في اكثر
من موقع وبحسب معلومات الشرطه والبيان
الاولي للتحقيقات الاوليه التي اجرتها فقد
قام بطعن امراه في البدايه بداخل سيارتها
وثم استولى على هذه المركبه وانتقل من
موقع الى اخر وقام بدهس عدد من
الاسرائيليين